- [Man] Do you know of a place
I could use the bathroom then?
Like where's a good public bathroom here?
Over 40 million people visit
Los Angeles every year,
now that is a lot of butts.
I'm here in Hollywood
to find out what makes
a good public bathroom, and what makes one
safe enough to poop in.
Is there anyway to make a public bathroom
feel safe enough to poop in?
- No.
- How do you decide
which business to choose?
- I mean I think a department store
is always a safe bet.
- From the look of the
building you can see
if the bathroom is clean or not so...
- So you think the facade
of the building is sexy,
the bathroom is good?
- When I come to Hollywood I go clubbing
so I'll just use a bathroom at the club.
- Hollywood, I don't think
has a great bathroom game.
But I'm going to try to
find the one good bathroom
that we've gotta have somewhere.
- Okay.
- We're in the car right now
on our way to our first stop
and I realize that I'm actually
starting to have to poop,
like for reals.
This is the exact scenario I was fearing
for all of our tourists and now here I am
experiencing it myself.
So we've got to find a restaurant,
we've got to find a department store,
and I just have got to
find normal public restroom
somewhere in this mall.
Ah, level three, and level two.
Let's head to level two.
Are we moving?
It says we're on two,
were we on two already?
- [Voiceover] Maybe?
- Well how do I get out?
We were already on the second floor, oops!
I'll take care of it from here.
Bam!
This bathroom is too crowded,
this is never going to work.
We're going to the third floor.
There were just so many people there.
How could that have been a clean bathroom?
Oh, maybe it was though?
Maybe that's why it was so popular.
Let's get a look here.
There was pee on the seat.
(sigh)
I can't sit down on that my legs
will get wet with urine.
Let's keep looking.
One of our rules was to find a place
with a beautiful exterior so I thought
maybe this Victoria's Secret.
I'm going to see if they have a bathroom,
just that they could let me use.
You guys' don't have
bathrooms here do you?
- Are those the public bathrooms?
- Are there any like secret,
nicer bathrooms around here?
- No nice bathrooms here?
- No, it's good to know.
My zipper is down, oops.
We are at a preposterously
crowded Starbucks
and I'm going to see if I can
possibly use their bathroom.
- Hello.
- Hi, do I have to buy
anything to use the bathroom?
- Nope.
- Don't need to buy anything, we're good.
It's a public bathroom.
It was a really nice bathroom
like and this is in the
center of Hollywood.
There must be dozens of
people using this bathroom
all the time.
So props to Starbucks for having actually
the cleanest bathroom I've encountered.
But wait, there's another public restroom.
Maybe they can redeem themselves.
Stop peeing on the seat!
There's pee on the seat.
Let's try Dave & Buster's.
It's like a department store for fun
like there's so much fun.
- [Man] Good, do you guys
have a bathroom I could use?
- Yeah, we do.
- This place is incredible.
Okay, this is pretty good.
There's toilet paper on the floor
but it's the whole roll.
It's clean, there is toilet paper here.
Toilet seat covers.
This is a pretty good bathroom.
And I didn't have to spend
any money playing games
although I want too.
Yeah, let's do it.
(bathroom noises)
We did it, we found a place to poop.
And now guys, let's play
some (bleep) video games.
Okay, let's play some (bleep) video games.
Let's get the BuzzFeed card
and get ourselves some
fun at Dave & Buster's.
I used 25 dollars of BuzzFeed's money
to get two shot glasses
and Laffy-Taffy Rope.
I think today has been a good day.